ILYA GRIGORIK: Hi everyone,
my name is Ilya Grigorik.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Make the Web
Fast Team at Google.
And today I want to talk to you
about Mobile Performance
from Radio Up, which is to say,
taking a lower level look
at how the radio works, and what
we can learn about it to
make our apps, mobile apps, and
web pages more performant.
So these are some tips and
tricks that I've learned from
working with different Google
properties, helping them
optimize their applications,
and some
general best practices.
So first I think we should start
with the obvious, or
maybe it's not so obvious to
many of us, which is, wireless
is fundamentally different
than wired.
There are different
constraints.
The technology, the underlying
technology, is,
in fact, very different.
And fortunately or
unfortunately, I'm not quite
sure yet, our platform actually
abstracts that.
TCP and our browsers make it
seem like it's all the same,
whether you're accessing over
a wireless network, whether
it's Wi-Fi, a mobile network,
or a wired network, it feels
like all the same.
But once you actually dig a
little bit deeper, you'll
realize that there are different
design constraints,
even within the different
wireless standards.
And that actually dictates how
you need to design your
applications to make them
feel performant.
So first of all,
why do we care?
It turns out that performance
is a top criteria for all
applications, mobile
especially.
And there's a number of great
studies that have been done
about performance on mobile.
And the first takeaway is that
users expect mobile sites to
perform just as well, if not
better, on mobile than they do
on desktop.
We don't have more relaxed
expectations on mobile.
If anything, it should
be faster.
You're on the go.
You're trying to check
something quickly.
You don't have much time.
You want it to perform well.
Now, out of all these users that
have asked this question,
more than half have actually
reported feeling frustrated
about having a problem when
accessing a site or an app
over a mobile network.
And most of those, the number
one complaint has been the
slow load time for their
applications.
And after that, almost half of
them said, if I had a problem,
I couldn't get the page to load
fast enough, it didn't
react fast enough, they
wouldn't come back.
So you've lost that user, and
they're not returning to your
site, which is the worst
possible outcome.
And of course, this also
translates to dollars and
cents, and even millions
of dollars.
So this another great case study
that I'd like to share.
This is done by Aberdeen
Group.
They looked at a whole number,
100-plus e-commerce sites, and
they realized that adding one
second of delay to their pages
and to their applications
dropped their conversions
significantly.
So this is your actual
purchases.
People viewed fewer pages,
and, of course, customer
satisfaction decreased
as well.
So this is just 1,000
milliseconds of latency added
to your application.
So it's not just dollars
and cents.
For many sites, large
sites, it's
literally millions of dollars.
So our agenda today is to
actually look at Radio
Performance 101.
It's kind of a propeller
hat talk, a little bit.
And specifically, we'll compare
Wi-Fi and mobile.
And you'll see why because it's
important to understand
that even something like Wi-Fi
and mobile networks are
fundamentally different in
how we schedule, how the
communication is done, and how
we design our applications, or
what we can even do to optimize
our applications.
And we'll also look at some
practical tips for what you
can do in your applications
to design for this.
And then I'll leave the last
part for you, which is to
optimize the profit part.
So there are tons and tons of
techniques for how to make
your applications
more performant.
There is application
optimizations.
There's HTTP-specific
optimizations, or
HTTP1-specific optimizations.
We are not going to
touch on those.
We're going to mention
them at the very end.
We're actually going to go
a little bit deeper.
We're going to go below the
application layer, even below
the TCP layer, and kind of look
at, like, how does the
radio actually work?
So we'll put the wired stuff
aside, look at the radio, and
dive into Wi-Fi and mobile.
So 3G and 4G, what's so
special about that?
How does battery life
play into this?
It turns out the battery
life is kind
of the central component.
There's the radio.
Then there's the battery,
those are two connected
components that we need
to think about.
And what is the radio
resource controller?
Our friend and foe.
So let's dive right it.
First of all, wireless, or
Wi-Fi, came around in the
early '90s.
That's when the first standards
were published.
But really, it only became
popular in the late '90s with
the release of the B802.11B
standard, which is the 11
megabits per second standard.
And the thing to realize about
Wi-Fi is, it was literally
designed as an extension
to your Local Area
Network, your LAN.
So we reuse all the same
framing, protocols,
mechanisms, all the rest of
them, and basically added a
wireless interface to it.
So it is not designed for a
mobile device, which is to
say, a device with
limited battery.
It was designed for
your desktop
computer, your laptop computer.
We weren't constrained
by power at the time.
Think back to the phone
that you had in 1999.
We weren't thinking about the
kinds of applications that
we're delivering at the time.
And the thing about Wi-Fi is,
we need to understand how we
actually schedule, how we
communicate, over Wi-Fi.
So when we're communicating over
a wired connection, we
have a switch, or a router,
which routes all the packets
between the client and
server, for example.
In Wi-Fi, we share the
radio channel.
And the radio channel
is a shared medium
between all of us.
All of us can't talk
at the same time.
That would just generate
a lot of noise.
So we need some sort of a
mechanism to figure out who's
going to talk when.
And Wi-Fi takes a very hands
off approach about this.
It basically says, let's use a
very simple algorithm, which
is, if you want to talk,
first listen if
nobody else is talking.
If nobody else is talking
then start talking.
And if another person starts
talking while you're talking,
well then, both of you stop,
wait for random interval of
time, and repeat the
whole process.
So it's kind of like this party
algorithm of hey, we'll
just trust that all of you
behave nicely, and you'll all
respect each other.
And we'll just kind of
share this medium.
That's Wi-Fi.
Now you can actually model
this and prove that the
channel load, or the amount of
traffic, needs to be kept
fairly low.
In fact, the load of the network
needs to be below 10%
in order to achieve
good performance.
You're always going to
have retransmissions.
There will always be the case
when I start talking, and you
start talking a little bit
later, and we collide.
But that's OK, because we will
wait, and then we'll
retransmit data, and
everything's OK.
You can get pretty
good performance.
But after a while, you basically
run into this case
where there are too many devices
trying to compete for
the same medium, and the network
basically collapses.
There's no way to recover
from this state.
And I'm pretty sure all of us
have experienced this at some
point, right?
Wi-Fi and a large group
of people in a room?
Not a good combination,
oftentimes.
So that's, in part, why.
And we can dig a little bit
deeper and actually look at
how it's implemented.
So in the 2.4 gigahertz
spectrum, we actually have a
limited amount of spectrum,
let's say 60 megahertz.
Within that 60 megahertz, we
can actually have three
channels, which is to
say up to three
devices can talk in parallel.
And they won't interfere
with each other.
So these are the channels.
If you guys have ever dug into
your settings on your Wi-Fi
router, that would be your
channel one, channel six, or
channel 11, or something
to that extent.
Now the problem is, this is
nice nice and pretty--
this is a little chart
that I pulled up
on my own home network.
And you can see that there's
over a dozen networks.
And they're all overlapping.
We're all trying to talk
over each other.
And basically, Wi-Fi to
some degree, is a
victim of its own success.
It has become so ubiquitous.
There's so many Wi-Fi routers
out there that it's very hard
to get a slot to talk to
somebody without interfering
with anybody.
So your neighbor, when they
start streaming that HD
Netflix movie, they're
interfering with you as well.
Even though it's a different
access point, they're still
using the same shared
spectrum.
So there is limited capacity.
And most networks have tens,
or even more than dozens of
overlapping networks.
So here's a fun experiment.
I ran this at my house.
So this is not definitive data,
but this is an example,
a data point.
There's about 15 access
points just in
and around my apartment.
And I ran this very
simple test.
I took my laptop, and I had
my router, which was
about 15 feet away.
And I was staring right at it.
And I figured hey, how long does
it take for one packet to
get from my laptop
to my router?
Like what is the latency
of that first hop?
And I gathered data
for several hours.
So this is a good
sample of data.
And if you look at the numbers
here, the 95th percentile is
about 50 milliseconds.
So to travel 15 feet from my
laptop to my router, it was
taking about 50 milliseconds,
which is crazy because 50
milliseconds is about the amount
of time it takes to
travel from the West Coast
to the East Coast.
So here I am trying to shuttle
a packet 15 feet away to my
wireless router.
So this is a function of,
there's just a lot of other
activity in the vicinity,
so we're competing
for the same spectrum.
So then I tried something
different.
I actually went out and bought
a different router, which is
using the new 802.11N standard
and it's running on the 5
gigahertz band.
And the 5 gigahertz band gives
us more bandwidth.
And by the function of the fact
that it's also new, not
many people are using it.
So I was the lone person
on that channel, and I
ran the same test.
And there you go, my 95th
percentile latency is down to
two milliseconds.
So as far as I'm concerned,
that was a fantastic
investment.
So if nothing else, you can go
back home, upgrade your router
to 5 gigahertz, hope that not
many of you are living in the
same neighborhood, and you're
not competing with each other,
and then you'll get much
better performance, web
performance.
We just cut 50 milliseconds
of latency.
That is huge for performance.
So some takeaways from this.
First of all, Wi-Fi makes no
guarantees about the bandwidth
or the data rate you're
going to get.
Anybody else can start
transmitting at
any point in time.
So it's unpredictable.
One way to deal with
this is to adapt to
the variable bandwidth.
Not to predict it--
you can't predict it.
You can only adapt to it.
So we leverage this to, for
example, serve video.
When we serve video on YouTube,
we serve it in small
chunks, like 5 to 10 second
chunks where we stream a chunk
of video, we see if you can
download it fast enough.
If you can download it fast
enough, we can upgrade you to
a higher quality stream.
Vice versa, if your bandwidth
was all of a sudden cut in
half because somebody else is
streaming a video, we will
downgrade you seamlessly to
a lower resolution video.
So that's adaptive streaming.
And that's something you can do
as well if you're streaming
music, streaming video,
or other things.
The other variable that you
can't really control with
Wi-Fi is, of course,
latency and jitter.
So because we have these
collisions all the time, and
your packets need to be
retransmitted, and there's not
much you can do.
Wi-Fi provides no guarantees
about this.
So if you've ever tried to
implement a real time chat or
real time voice and video over
Wi-Fi, you've certainly run
into this problem.
So perhaps the only thing you
can really do is start looking
into something like WebRTC which
allows you to leverage
unreliable delivery and
basically [? UDP ?]
in a browser.
And we had a great session
on WebRTC earlier today.
So if you guys missed it, check
out the video for that.
So that's Wi-Fi.
So that's just a baseline.
Now let's take a look at
2G, 3G, 4G networks.
How do they work and how
are they different?
So first of all, when the mobile
standards started they
set aside some specific
constraints that they needed
to optimize for.
First is they needed to
guarantee some level of
performance.
So they wanted to make sure
that they don't have this
congestion collapse scenario
which is present in Wi-Fi.
They want to have some knobs to
tweak to say, if this is a
really overloaded network,
we will lower the
data rates for everybody.
But you can still sort of
get a lower data rate.
But we want to be able
to control that.
And we need some
knobs for that.
So that's number one.
Second is, of course we're
covering a much larger
geographical area, which means
that, once again, we need to
handle more clients.
And that's something we
need to account for.
And the second one is
our battery life.
So it turns out, when you're
optimizing for mobile devices,
you really need to think
about battery life.
I think, for many of us, if
we use our mobile device
actively, you'll find that your
batteries is draining
very, very quickly.
So radio is a very important
component of that.
You add these two things
together, and you get the
Radio Resource Controller.
And what is the Radio
Resource Controller?
So mobile networks, the 2G, 3G,
and 4G standards, take a
different approach as to how
they schedule when you can
communicate.
Instead of doing this freebie
approach of you just start
talking when you think nobody
else is talking, they're
actually employing a moderator,
which is to say,
the radio tower actually tells
you when you can speak.
You tell the radio tower
that hey, I would like
to send some data.
And then the radio tower
consults its schedule and
tells you, OK, I've got
these five people
that are queued up.
You're this far away.
So you start transmitting at
this point in time with this
signal power, with these
parameters, with this
encoding, and then you have
this amount of time.
So it's a very different
scheduling mechanism.
And as you can imagine, this
adds a lot more overhead.
But it allows us to schedule
resources more efficiently
within the network.
And this obviously has
its pros and cons.
So the Radio Resource Controller
lives within a
different component of the
network infrastructure.
In 2G and 3G network,
it was actually
living in the core network.
In the latest networks, it is
living right at the radio
tower, which is one of the ways
of how we're improving
performance in 4G networks.
By moving it closer to you,
we're reducing the latency.
But the Radio Resource
Controller has a number of
implications.
So the first of these is the
difference and the distinction
between the control and the
user-plane latency.
So whenever you talk to anybody
that's working in the
mobile space, they'll often
throw this out and mention the
control-plane latency.
What is it?
Recall that we need to talk to
the radio tower to figure out
when we're allowed to
transfer the data.
This is what happens.
First, you send a message to the
radio tower, and you say,
I'd like to send data.
The radio tower determines
when you can talk.
And then it sends you
a message back.
That is the control-plane
latency.
And in 3G networks, this can
take up to 2 and 1/2 seconds.
2 and 1/2 seconds.
We haven't even sent a packet
of data, application data,
from your phone, we're just
basically trying to get a
resource assignment from
the radio tower.
In 4G networks, and the latest
generation networks, this time
is significantly improved.
It's under 100 milliseconds.
But nonetheless, every
millisecond counts, and 100
milliseconds is a significant
amount of time.
And then only after we've
incurred this cost, and we've
gotten our resource assignment,
can we then start
transmitting data from our
phone to the radio tower.
And that is known as the
user-plane latency.
And for example, in 4G networks,
that can be about 10
milliseconds.
So we are definitely in the
weeds here looking at how the
mobile radio works.
But some important
takeaways there.
Let's take this from
the ground up.
Your phone is idle.
It's been asleep.
You take it out of
your pocket.
You start typing a URL.
You hit go.
What happens?
So this is a 4G network.
First, we need to talk
to the tower.
So we're going to occur
at least 100
milliseconds of latency.
Then our phone is active and
starts transmitting data, or
the radio is active, and it
starts transmitting data.
After some time, it will
actually downgrade your radio
into a short sleep cycle, which
is to say, it's not
going to listen for
transmissions all the time.
It'll sleep for some time, and
it'll wake up periodically to
save power.
It turns out that the radio is
the second most expensive
component in terms of power or
energy use in your phone after
the screen.
So this is why we want
to turn off the radio
as quickly as possible.
And in the case of 4G networks,
this is usually done
after 100 milliseconds of
inactivity on your radio.
So we've transmitted
some data.
We wait for a 100 millisecond
pause, and then we downgrade
your radio into this
half sleep state.
And at that point, if you want
to transmit data again, we
need to go through that whole
control-plane cycle once more.
So you're once again incurring
this same cost.
But then, if your phone
continues to be idle, we wait
for another 100 milliseconds.
We go into the second, the
long sleep mode, and only
after about 10 seconds,
we will go back
into the idle mode.
So a kind of pretty complicated
flow chart.
But effectively, what this says
is, first, we have to
incur the cost to upgrade
the radio.
And then it takes a roughly
10 seconds to get
back to idle mode.
And this is very important,
as you'll see in a second.
So let's put this together.
This is pretty low level.
How does the effect an actual
data transfer, something like
an HTTP data transfer?
So let's start from
the beginning.
We want to send a request, which
means we need to do a
DNS lookup.
We may need to do
a DNS lookup.
We need to do a TCP handshake,
followed by dispatching the
actual HTTP request, and
then we actually need
to fetch the content.
And maybe optionally, we need
to do the TLS handshake,
another up to two round
trips there.
So let's add up all
these numbers.
First of all, we have the
control plane latency, which
is the time to wake up
the radio and get
into the active state.
So I'm using HSPA here,
which is a 3G network.
And I'm using an average round
trip time of about 200
milliseconds, which is roughly
the time that we see at Google
for 3G networks.
And then, for 4G networks, these
new generation networks,
let's use 80 milliseconds
which is actually fairly
aggressive.
So 200 to 2.5 seconds, so 200
milliseconds to 2 and 1/2
seconds, just to get out of
control-plane for the 3G network.
And then we have these round
trips to fetch the DNS, to
establish TCP, and
all the rest.
And very quickly, you add
up all these numbers.
This is without your server
response time.
We already have over
half a second of
just network latency.
And this is very important if
you're trying to design a
responsive application that
feels responsive to the user.
So the good news is, things are
definitely getting better
and better with 4G.
We're down into hundreds
of milliseconds and
half a second territory.
But we also can't rely on 4G,
as you'll see in a second.
So really, you should assume
that there is literally
seconds of network latency
overhead when you design your
applications.
So the first takeaway here is,
we know that there are some
constants that good applications
need to follow.
A number of different User
Experience Research studies
have shown that, in order for
an app to feel instant, they
need to respond to the user, it
needs to acknowledge user
input within hundreds
of milliseconds.
And we just saw that, even on
the latest 4G network, you're
incurring 300 to 500
milliseconds, which means that
you, basically, you cannot wait
for the HTTP request, or
any request, to complete.
You need to acknowledge the user
input independently of
dispatching the request.
So acknowledge the input.
Send the request in
the background.
That is the only way you will
have an application that feels
instant to the user.
So all communication should
be asynchronous.
Similarly, you should anticipate
the RRC latency.
It's a very common complaint
about mobile network that, oh
my god, they're so
unpredictable, the variability
is so high.
Turns out, once you're aware of
the control-plane latency,
or of this negotiation at the
beginning, which is the time
to wake up your radio, you can
model this stuff very well.
And you can build, and you can
bake these things into the
design process of your
application.
Once you talk to the designers,
and you let them
know that, hey, it may actually
take two seconds
before we can do anything, like
even send an application
packet, they can design your
application in a way that
provides some sort of feedback
to the user that, hey, we're
working on processing
your input, but
it may take a while.
All right, so moving on,
we talked about energy.
So this is another gotcha that,
I think, is top of mind
for a lot of applications that
are native applications, but
is not yet top of mind for a
lot of web applications.
But it certainly will be soon.
So notice that, in our earlier
diagram, we said it takes
about 10 seconds to cycle from
a high power state into a low
power state.
This actually causes what is
known as an energy tail, where
it doesn't matter how much data
you have transferred, the
radio will be active for a
certain period of time.
Like, you could have transferred
one bit or one
byte of data.
It doesn't matter.
Or you could have transferred
10 kilobytes, or 100
kilobytes of data.
The radio's going to be on,
effectively, for 10 seconds
after that.
So you're not going
to save much by
sending data bit by bit.
What you want to do is, you want
to send as much data as
possible as early as possible.
And in fact, intermittent data
transfers is a huge huge
performance anti pattern
on mobile.
So I have an example of this.
An average mobile device today
has about five Watt-hours of
battery capacity.
And don't worry about
the units too much.
This is just to illustrate
a point.
And five Watt-hours is
about 18,000 joules.
And it turns out that an average
phone today of a 4G
connection, in order to cycle
from a low state, to high
state, back to low state,
will take about
10 joules of energy.
Let's do our math.
Let's say we have one minute
pulling interval.
So I built an application,
like a Gmail application,
which, every minute, will wake
up and just ping the server
and say, do I have an email?
Are there any messages for me?
You multiply that out, it
turns out that this
application will consume 3%
of battery life per hour.
Now you have a couple of
these applications
running on your phone.
They have non-overlapping
intervals.
You have your phone in your
pocket for half a day, you
take it out, your battery
is at 25%.
And you're wondering what
the heck happened there?
That's what happened there.
We're doing these intermittent
things and that was draining
the battery.
So intermittent data transfers
are extremely expensive.
And there's a really cool case
study that was done as a joint
case study between
AT&T and Pandora.
They analyzed the native Pandora
application, which is,
of course, a music streaming
application.
And then discovered something
interesting.
Pandora was doing all
the right things.
When they were streaming
music, you would
start playing the song.
They would stream the entire
song down to the client and
just play the whole thing.
So they would turn off the
radio, which is exactly what
you want to do.
But then, about every, I think,
58 seconds, or 60
seconds, Pandora would fire an
analytics beacon which was
reporting how far along did you
listen in the song, did
you like the song, and
all the rest--
it seems reasonable.
They analyzed it and realized
that those data transfers were
accounting to 0.2% of the total
bytes transferred, but
it was 46% of the battery life
of that application, which is
a huge, of course, performance
problem.
So all they had to
do was to move--
these are not critical
beacons.
They could simply defer that
until later, until the next
song data transfer that could
accumulate this data.
And they did exactly that, and
they significantly improved
the performance of their
application.
So here are a couple
of examples.
It's a little bit small, but I
was looking at, for example
CNN.com here.
And I noticed that they have a
real time analytics beacon
installed on their site.
So whenever you're reading a
CNN article on your mobile
phone, about every five seconds
[? Charredbeat ?]
sends a beacon saying,
I'm still here.
Yep, I'm still here.
Yep, I'm still alive.
And guess, as you're reading
CNN, you're just draining your
battery, which is not
a great experience.
So in Google Analytics, we
actually caught this
problem early on.
And we fixed it.
And we don't do this.
We have a different way, where
we provide real time
analytics, but we have a way to
do that without requiring
these beacons.
So the short takeaway is, if you
are sending these kinds of
beacons in your application,
web or native, definitely
something to reconsider because
it's extremely expensive.
Now unfortunately today, I don't
think many platforms
provide very good
instrumentation or visibility
into how much energy does
my application consume--
whether that's web or native.
But one tool that is actually
very good is the AT&Ts Arrow
tool, which is a free and
open source tool.
And I will show you guys
a quick demo of this.
I've have it running here.
So what it allows you to do is,
it allows you to capture a
trace file.
You can actually install an
application on your Android
device, you hit Record, and
you interact with your
application.
Then you export a trace, and you
can analyze it with this
analyzer tool.
So I've already prerecorded a
trace, and I'm just going to
show it to you guys here.
So let me load this app here.
And you can also run it in an
emulator, but I prefer to do
it on my phone.
So I loaded a website.
I have this trace.
One of the cool things is
provides is, it can actually
record your screen.
So here I'm starting
Collector.
And I'll just fast forward
a little bit.
So I'm loading the site
Red Robin here.
And you can actually look at the
diagnostics screen here.
And you can see this
line moving here.
So this is us downloading the
page, and you can see the
throughput, the different RFC
states, or the states of the
radio, and the energy
consumption on your app.
So let me pause this.
And one of the cool things
about this tool is, it'll
actually also analyze the
content that you're
downloading and point
out common
performance anti patterns.
Things like, hey, you're
not caching the data.
Or you have intermittent
data transfers.
But then, on top of all of that,
it'll also tell you the
energy consumed during this
session that you've recorded.
So you can actually
model this.
Now one thing to call out
is, this is not an exact
measurement.
This is based on a model.
So it has some assumptions about
the phone that you're
using and the network
type you're on.
So you can actually switch those
and say, I want to run
this model on a 3G network
instead of a 4G network.
So if nothing else, this is
a great tool to play with.
And I encourage you guys
to check it out.
I hope that in the future we'll
have more tools like
this baked right into our kind
of day to day dev tools, both
on native and web platforms.
So it is all about
the battery.
It literally is all
about the battery.
Whenever you're wondering why
doesn't my mobile radio behave
in a certain way, always ask
the question how does it
impact my battery life?
And you often find
the answer there.
Radio at full power, if it's
on all the time, will
literally drain your battery
in a matter of hours.
If you've ever had your phone
burning your leg, you know how
that feels, what's usually
happening there is, you can't
get a connection, and some
application is just
continuously trying
to reconnect.
And that turns on the
radio at full power.
It drains your battery like
there's no tomorrow.
And the actual transfer
size does not matter.
It doesn't matter if
you're transferring
one byte or 100 kilobytes.
That's the other important
takeaway.
So the consequence of that is,
you want to pre-fetch data.
I'll fetch the previews and the
thumbnails of my awesome
application, and then, as you
scroll, I'll fetch the rest.
That's an anti pattern
on mobile.
You want to pre-fetch as much
data as possible, turn off the
radio, and then hopefully
keep it off
for as long as possible.
And we already talked about
periodic data transfers.
So what can you do there.
You can defer the request
until later.
You can combine them.
You can launch that data into
a local database like local
storage and then fire
the request later.
Of course, we provide some
tools for this, both on
Android and Chrome.
So Google Cloud Messaging is
definitely something that you
guys should check out
and leverage.
And what it allows you to do is,
you can push notifications
to our servers, to the Google
Cloud Messaging servers, and
then those servers will try to
determine an optimal strategy
to deliver those messages to
your phone by minimizing the
amount of data transfers.
So for example, we
just launched
the support on Chrome.
We don't yet have feature
parity with Android.
I hope we get there quick.
But for example, on Android,
you can actually mark a
message as delay while idle--
which is to say, if the user's
phone is idle, don't
push it right now.
But when they wake up their
phone, push the message there.
And not only that, but if you're
going to delay the
message, this is the
time to live.
If the user doesn't wake up
their phone within the next
hour, just drop the message on
the floor because it's no
longer relevant.
And it's the combination of
these things that allow you to
build efficient applications,
where you can have efficient
delivery of these messages to
the phone without necessarily
having to wake up the phone or
having your phone wake up
periodically and query
your service, which
clearly does not scale.
So that's a little bit about
how the radio works on the
phone itself.
Now let's take a deep dive into
how the mobile network,
the core network, actually
works, and what implications
it has on performance.
So at a very high level, the
mobile network effectively has
a couple of important
components.
The first one is the
packet gateway.
And the way to think about the
packet gateway is, it's
basically like your wireless
router, or your
router at your house.
It's a NAT device which
accepts all of the
connections.
It terminates all of
the connections.
And then it forwards the packets
to your device, in
this case, a mobile device.
And there's an important pause
here, which is, your
connection, or the connection
to your phone between the
server to your phone, is not
an end to end connection.
It is being terminated
by this router.
So just the fact that you're
turning off your radio, or
you're pressing the power button
on your phone, does not
terminate the TCP connection,
which I think is a common
misconception.
And if you're ever seeing this
kind of pattern, where you
have your code basically saying,
look, if I turn off
the radio, I'm going to lose
my WebSocket connection or
something else, that is not true
because the connection is
still maintained by
the radio network.
And it will wake up your radio
when it's necessary.
So if you have code like this
in your application, you
definitely want to
turn that off.
Most carriers have, actually,
timeouts of anywhere between
five to 30 minutes for
a TCP connection.
If anything, I've found that, by
working with many different
apps, it's usually the
application server on your
side that's terminating the
connection early on.
Like you have aggressive
timeouts of 60 seconds.
And then, because of that, your
app needs to periodically
pull your server to
keep it open.
So make sure that that
plumbing is correct.
It's not the carriers
in most cases.
OK, so we've got the
packet gateway.
The packet gateway has
no idea about the
location of your device.
What it actually does is, it
forwards the packets to the
serving gateway.
And the serving gateway needs
to figure out, where are you
and where is your device?
The trick is, the
serving gateway
doesn't know that either.
It basically needs to query a
local database, like a user
database, to say which radio
tower are you currently
associated with.
And how is your billing
status?
Should I even be forwarding
this packet to begin with?
So that's this mobility
management entity.
So just like a user database.
That's all it is.
All right, so let's try this.
Let's say we want to send a data
packet from your phone.
We can actually connect all
the pieces together now.
First, my device is
going to wake up.
And the first component is,
it's going to talk to the
radio tower.
It's going to negotiate the
times when it can send data.
That will take hundreds of
milliseconds, or up to two
seconds on 3G networks.
After that, it will transfer
data to the radio tower.
The radio tower will transfer
it to the serving gateway,
which will forward it to the
packing gateway, and only then
will it hit the external
network.
And this is when the data is
transferred to your server and
all the rest.
The latencies for this
end-to-end transferring here,
without the external network,
is anywhere between 50
milliseconds to hundreds
of milliseconds
on different networks.
I pulled out these numbers from
the AT&T technical FAQ.
So basically, the takeaway here
is 4G, 50 milliseconds,
plus the transfer time to use
server, on 3G, as high as 400
milliseconds and much, much
worse for 2G networks.
It turns out, that's
a simple case.
Let's try the more
complicated case.
And I hope you guys
stay with me here.
Let's say we actually want to
push a packet to the device.
So we're trying to wake
up the device.
Our server pushes a packet
to the mobile carrier.
It hits the packet gateway.
That goes to the serving
gateway.
The server gateway,
once again, has no
idea where you are.
One of the nice properties of
mobile networks is, well, you
guys are mobile.
You hop into a car.
Now you're on your way
out of San Francisco.
We have no idea where you are.
So the serving gateway actually
talks to the mobility
management here, and it says,
OK, I need to send this packet
to this user.
Tell me where to forward
the packet to?
The mobility interface doesn't
actually know your current
physical location.
It knows, kind of
geographically, where you are.
OK, last time he checked in,
he was in San Francisco.
So it sends a ping to
all of the radio
towers in the vicinity.
And says just flood the entire
network with a beacon that
says, hey you, user number blah,
blah, blah, there's a
packet waiting for you.
Identify yourself, please.
Your radio wakes up.
It gets that packet.
It then talks to the tower.
It says, hey, I'm here.
I'm associated with
you right now.
That data gets transferred
back.
It goes back to the serving
gateway, and now it can
transfer the data back to the
tower and to your device.
This is pretty complicated.
And the reason I'm pointing
this out is, oftentimes,
there's a question of
why does it take 200
milliseconds to do this?
I mean, but clearly,
this is a pretty
complicated problem to solve.
So the fact that we can do this
in 40 to 50 milliseconds
in 4G is actually or rather
impressive, to be honest.
So this is a little crazy.
But is it worth it?
I think that's a valid
question to ask.
We went from Wi-Fi, where
we had nothing.
We just said, just talk
and hope for the best.
Cross our fingers.
We went to this 4G network
interface, where now we have
all these routers, radio towers
talking to each other,
it's all crazy.
Where are we going?
So this is a great case study
that was done a couple years
back, actually, in 2011, where
they measured performance of
Wi-Fi networks, typical
home router networks.
I think this was done with
802.11G, so a fairly new
standard, and they compared
it against LTE.
So just focus on these
two clusters here.
And what I want to point out
is, first of all, the
throughput is actually better.
But most importantly is this
graph right here, which is the
round trip time for
our packets.
With Wi-Fi, there's no
guarantees about the latency
of the delivery of
your packets.
And that's why you have these
giant tails here.
Generally speaking, the latency
is fairly low, but
then you have these outliers,
which is why
this line is stretched.
With LTE, even though it's
so much more seemingly
complicated, or not just
seemingly, it is more
complicated, we can actually
deliver more reliable latency
and lower jitter across
the network.
So this is good.
This is great.
4G will make things better.
So a couple of things.
Mobile radio is optimized for
burst data transfers.
It is not optimized for sending
bits in small chunks.
What you want to do is, you want
to transfer as much data
as possible and then
turn off the radio.
And in fact, the latest 4G
networks can transfer on the
order of 10 of megabits per
second, which is really high
data rates.
But it will do so in very
small assignments.
In fact, the bandwidth
assignments are done in
millisecond and lower chunks.
So you get a chunk of airspace
for about one millisecond, and
you can transfer huge
amounts of data.
So pack as much data
as you can.
Group your requests.
Don't delay your requests.
The not so good news part of the
4G world is that 4G will
take a while to come.
Despite the fact that there is
ads everywhere, across all the
highways and everywhere else
that 4G will save all things,
4G will take a while
to deploy.
Current carriers have
deployed a lot of
infrastructure for 3G.
And they're continuing to
improve that, in part because
they can, and in part because
it's very expensive.
So the dominant network type
of this decade, not just of
this year, or in the coming
year, of this decade, will be
3G networks.
And granted, they are being
enhanced to deliver higher
data rates.
But nonetheless, you can see
that the growth, overall
growth projections, are
for 3G networks.
The good news is, at least
within North America, LTE and
HSPA, which are the 4G networks,
are actually taking
off quite well.
In fact, we are way ahead of the
curve compared to all the
other countries.
But nonetheless, you have to
basically assume that your
users will be using a mix
of 3G and 4G networks.
And even if you have a 4G
network data plan on your
phone, your phone is switching
between 4G
and 3G all the time.
Depending on coverage, or where
you currently are, and
load within the network.
So because of that, you have to
design for variable network
performance and availability.
It is truly a multi-generation
future.
You can't assume that you'll get
great performance with 4G.
You need to plan for 3G
networks as well.
Bandwidth and latency
are variable.
And of course, as we've all
experienced, connectivity is
intermittent.
So if you're building a mobile
application, or an application
for the mobile web, you have to
assume that there should be
an offline mode or some fallback
to say what happens
when I can't actually connect.
And I mentioned this before,
but I think this is an
important point to
make once again.
You should have some sort
of a backup strategy.
Oftentimes, the reason we have
poor battery performance is
because some application does
not plan for intermittent
connectivity, or the fact that
there is no connectivity, and
it just continues to pull
the server to say,
are you there yet?
Are you there yet?
And that's what's burning your
leg and burning the battery on
your device.
What you want to do instead is
to say, I'm going to try to
connect now.
And then every time I fail, I
will just punt further out
into the future, have some sort
of a decay function, and
then say I'm going to stop
after this interval, and
you'll retry later.
Nine cases out of 10, whenever
I have a performance or a
battery life problem, I track
it down to exactly this.
It's some application
that's just
sitting there, in a loop--
while not connected,
keep trying.
Not a good strategy.
So with that, I think we've gone
through the full cycle.
And we're back to application
best practices.
Of course, all the radio stuff
is very important.
But optimizing TCP best
practices, TLS, and HTTP is
very important.
The takeaways here is, of
course, measure first.
Make sure you're using real user
measurement, and you're
measuring performance across
real networks.
Do that first, and then
optimize later.
And I'll just call out a couple
of examples that I
think are very important.
The fastest request is
a request not made.
This is an obvious one.
But it turns out, when we
analyze a lot of mobile
applications, they're
not caching data.
This is the number one problem
for a lot of applications.
So make sure you do that.
Bytes are literally expensive
for a lot of users.
You need to compress
resources.
And you know, it's funny because
we've been talking
about compressing resources,
compressing images, for years.
But we still find that a lot of
applications don't do it.
And of course, leveraging
formats like WebP, as you guys
heard at the keynote,
and we had a session
earlier today on WebP--
definitely encourage you to try
it both on web and native.
And then, finally, shameless
self promotion.
I've been writing a book on this
stuff, and, specifically,
on mobile radio performance
and other things.
And it's available
online for free.
So if you guys are curious to
learn more about this, and I
can talk about it all day,
please check it out and please
offer feedback.
You can actually comment
right on it.
And with that, I think we have
some time for questions.
If you can grab one of the
mics, and I'd be happy to
answer them.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Maurice.
I work for Verizon Wireless.
I have a question regarding APIs
or services that can be
provided by the Android
framework itself to allow
developers to make application
more efficient.
For example, the same way today
doesn't allow you to put
network access in your main
thread, is there anything
planned to do in that matter?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I have more
experience with the web part
of the stack.
So I can't necessarily comment
on the Android part.
I would actually direct you to
the Android guys sitting
outside for that.
But something like GCM, we
continue enhance GCM, or the
Google Cloud Messaging, and
that's what you want to use
for a lot of communication.
We just recently announced the
ability to actually send data
through GCM as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my understanding
of why LTE is much better is
partially because of the
modulation that it uses.
Since LTE uses LFDM, and Wi-Fi
uses something different.
Do you know if there's any
industry trends to move the
modulation scheme of the access
points that you might
have at home, to use that
technology over what we have
today, since it's so jittery?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So there's a
couple questions in there.
So LTE has a host of different
improvements.
So they're basically redesigning
the network from
the ground up.
They're moving the scheduling
stuff into the
edges of the network.
They're using a new modulation
scheme, as you described.
So it's not just a modulation.
Because that helps you
with throughput.
But there's a number of other
variables, like the energy
use, the latency of assumption,
the connection,
all the rest.
For moving that same technology
into, let's say,
your local access points,
yes to some degree.
So Wi-Fi standards and LTE,
or 3GPP, standards
are completely separate.
But just watching both of them,
they do borrow and steal
from each other.
So with the latest Wi-Fi
standards, you'll find that
the way they're achieving
gigabit data rates is by using
the same tricks, to
a large degree.
AUDIENCE: So do you know
if that's in 802 AC?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, that's
in part how they're--
yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm fairly new
to Android development.
And this may have been covered
in the messaging, cloud
messaging feature.
I was just wondering, is there
any currently, or plans to
provide support for aggregating
requests from the
OS level or framework to, if
you've got multiple apps
running that all have a stupid
beacon request, is there any
support for ganging these
together, so multiple apps
kind of work with each other
instead of against each other
to reduce radio usage?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, so I
think that's definitely
something that we're
looking at.
And that's something that only
the platform can provide.
As an application designer,
you can't control what the
other applications are doing.
So this is definitely something
that we're thinking
about, both on the web, like
on Chrome, for example, how
can Chrome leverage something
like this, and also within the
Android platform.
So a good example of this is
turning off the radio early.
If we know that there's no other
connections being made,
we can terminate the
connections early.
That can be done by the
operating system in
conjunction with the Radio
Resource Controller.
So yes, there's definitely
work in that direction.
AUDIENCE: So that's
nothing current,
but it's in the works?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
recommendations for tools just
as a user, to help figure out
what's killing your battery on
iOS and Android?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, so
I hope we make that
tooling much better.
I guess a couple of tips that
I use, one is, you actually
have the battery panel
within Android.
If you go into your settings and
kind of navigate down, it
actually gives you a really
good breakdown of which
applications consume power.
And if you click on the graph,
it will also show you kind of
a breakdown of when the power
is being consumed.
So I've found that that's the
most effective way to identify
specific applications.
I think we need to do more
to isolate, like,
at a webpage level.
There's nothing really
like that.
And I think we need something
So I hope we'll have a better
answer in a year's time.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, could you talk a
little bit about strategies
that you would use for games?
Because they have a completely
different data access pattern.
And they typically talk
UDP instead of TCP.
And they require lower latency
in case you're playing with
someone else.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So all of the
same optimization strategies
would apply there.
It doesn't matter if it's
TCP or UDP, you need
to wake up the radio.
So to the extent possible, you
want to aggregate data.
You don't want to be beaconing
back every single achievement
unlocked by the user if that
can be kept on the device.
So once again, leveraging things
like GCM and others to
aggregate that data,
it's all the same.
The protocol doesn't
actually matter.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: As a JavaScript
developer, the best practices,
as you said, is to batch API
requests or other requests.
Could you comment on the beacon
API, which would help
us tap into actually when
the radio is active.
ILYA GRIGORIK: The beacon API.
So are you talking about
the new proposal?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and then what
the status of that is.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, OK, so in
the HP performance working
group, we're working on a couple
of proposals, I guess.
One is the beacon API, which is
to say, I want you to send
this request, but I don't
actually care
when you send it.
Just send it when it's
convenient for you.
A good example of that
is analytics beacons.
You don't want to wake up
the radio right now.
You're just saying, defer
this and dispatch it
at some later time.
So there's no implementation
of that yet.
I think we have early
drafts of the spec.
If you guys are interested, I
would definitely encourage you
to check out the working group
and comment on it.
But hopefully, soon, we'll
have something.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk about
what tools you used to look at
your Wi-Fi networks
in those slides?
ILYA GRIGORIK: What is the
tool that I used in--
you know, I don't remember off
the top of my head, but if you
talk to me afterwards, I can
find it on my laptop.
AUDIENCE: A question
about analytics.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what solutions are
you currently working on
at Google not to lose the data
value, and to reduce the
battery consumption.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So for analytics,
what you generally
want to do-- so this is actually
related to the
previous question about
the beacon API.
So oftentimes, you can report
the data later.
So one strategy is to literally
stash the data into
your local database and
then report it when
the radio is active.
This requires some modifications
of your
application itself.
But for example, on the real
time analytics, we don't
actually ping back every
so often to just
say that you're there.
We do the real time analytics
differently, which is to say,
we track when you first visit
the page, which is when you
hit that beacon, and then we say
that you're active on the
page for the next 30 seconds.
And if you navigate to
another page, then
you're still active.
So we're not forcing this
five second interval.
And I think we need to talk to
the other vendors and get them
to move in the same direction
because they're literally
costing a lot in terms
of performance.
AUDIENCE: And about
Google Analytics,
and additional question.
Will it be a separate API
extended for request bulking?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Can you say
that again, sorry.
AUDIENCE: So for example, we
have a start in activity.
And we are reporting the user
when there is a start of
activity, and when he left it.
And there's a chain of them.
And will be the API of Google
Analytics extended, so we can
bufferize this, like put, and
put to buffer, and to report
later, or something like this.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's
a great idea.
So there's three ways
to tackle that.
Google Analytics can provide
a new API to basically say,
stash this and send it later.
You can implement your own
wrapper around it, and
basically say, I'm going to
fire this later, when I
consider that it's active.
And then the best approach, I
think, is a combination of the
two, which is the beacon API,
which we were just talking
about, which is basically a
browser mechanism, to say
we'll defer this to the browser
to determine because
it's actually in the
best position.
So today the fastest way to get
what you're talking about
is to implement it in
your application.
I can certainly talk to the
Google Analytics Team and see
if there is interest
in implementing
something like this.
I think that's a great idea.
And then, maybe in a year's
time, we'll have something
like the Beacon API.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: We're
way over time.
[INAUDIBLE]
ILYA GRIGORIK: All
right, one more.
AUDIENCE: My question is
related to the Nexus 4.
I've always used Verizon, and
I've never had any signal
reception issues until I
switched to T-Mobile.
At my house, on the first
floor, I only get edge.
On the second floor, I get
edge, but it's iffy.
On the third floor, I'll
get edge and HSPA+.
Now this is the thing, though.
With this phone, the decibel
rating, from what I'm reading,
is like around 100.
If I hold the phone in my
hand, I lose signal.
ILYA GRIGORIK: You're
holding it wrong.
AUDIENCE: But this
is the thing.
If I'm on a phone call, and
then I hold it, it doesn't
drop signal.
So my question is, is there a
way that I, as an end user,
can make the phone put more
power to the radio to hold the
signal because I can't
change T-Mobile.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the
short answer is no.
The energy use is actually
dictated by the radio tower.
It actually tells you, depending
on where you are,
the distance between you and the
radio tower, the amount of
other people talking, the exact
signal power that you
should be transmitting.
So in fact, the radio tower is
actually trying to help you
optimize your battery use, which
sounds like, in this
case, it may be working
against you.
But there's no explicit
control of that,
unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Great,
thanks guys.